bacteria are known to cause several
infectious disease like cholera
tuberculosis gastric ulcer meningitis
skin abscess leprosy Amtrak's and even
typhoid so whenever you are infected by
a bacteria and you have a bacterial
disease your drop doctor would prescribe
something called antibiotic and you
would come home and swallow that
antibiotic hoping that that antibiotic
would cure your disease but have you
ever wondered that how does these
antibiotics work so in this video I
would talk about more of action of
antibiotics so if you haven't yet
subscribed to my channel please hit that
subscribe button and don't forget to
like this video so antibiotics could
have two broad mode of actions one is
bactericidal that means it is killing
the bacteria and other is bacteriostatic
so bacteriostatic means pausing the
growth of the bacteria in other words
interfering with several metabolic and
physiological aspects of bacteria so
we'll just look at that how possibly
several antibiotics could work on
several aspects of bacterial growth
metabolism and overall physiology so
antibiotics like polymyxin B interferes
with the cell membrane and it it
actually make the cell membrane more
leaky and damage the cell membrane and
thereby the bacteria dies by osmolarity
disbalance and the pressure disbalance
other antibiotics like penicillin and
vancomycin interferes with several
aspects of cell wall synthesis and if
the cell wall is not synthesized
bacterias shield is gone it is almost
weak and there could be osmotic
disbalance due to different environment
and they are more susceptible to damages
other antibiotics like pure myosin
kanamycin neomycin streptomycin etc can
interfere with the protein synthesis
process now bacteria like other cells
need to produce its own protein enzymes
in order to keep on its metabolic demand
but all these protein synthesis is
checked by these kind of antibiotics and
thereby the severely interfering with
its day-to-day demand of several
metabolic enzymes now other aspect of
antibiotics such as ciprofloxacin
allylic sig acid and mitomycin c etc can
interfere with bacterial replication
process in order to reproduce bacteria
need to replicates its DNA and segregate
that DNA properly to its daughter cell
that's how a bacteria can reproduce but
if these antibiotics interfere with this
process of replication then they can
potentially harm the bacteria and can
eventually kill the bacteria as well so
today's focus would be how penicillin
works like an antibiotic and what is the
mode of action of penicillin so here is
our bacteria and if we zoom into the
bacteria we would see we have the cell
membrane on top of which which we have
cell wall now cell wall is formed of a
polymer of n acetyl glucosamine and an
acetyl Meramec acid now in acid L
glucosamine and n-acetylmuramic acid
polymer are interlinked by a
pentapeptide bridge and inside the
pentapeptide bridge a peptide bond is
formed between meso
diam elopfamily acid and di learning and
this bond formation is catalyzed by
transpeptidase so penicillin in short
interferes with transpeptidase action
and thereby interfere with bacterial
cell membrane cell cell wall formation
process so let's just look at how
normally bacterial cell wall is formed
and what is the role of transpeptidase
information of the cell wall then we can
appreciate how penicillin can interfere
with the cell wall formation process so
inside the bacterial cell in the
bacterial cell inside the cytoplasm you
D be linked in acetyl Meramec acid is
linked with several pentapeptides by a
sequential enzymatic steps and that is
carried by a carrier known as
to preneur which but which is carrying
the in Ethel Merman acid linked
pentapeptide to the top of the cytoplasm
and what happens is UDP an acetate
glutamic glucose and mine interacts with
an acetyl Meramec acid and thereby it
forms the basic subunit for formation of
the cell wall now as the bacteria grows
the transpeptidase
enzyme bind to the specific d-alanine
d-alanine amino acid in its active site
and d-alanine d-alanine has a specific
structure which fits properly into the
active site of the transpeptidase and
thereby transpeptidase forms a peptide
bond between two pentapeptides from the
opposing sides and thereby the whole
polymer of cell wall is formed now what
penicillin does is it already binds to
the active site of the transpeptidase
because penicillin has a very similar
structure like d-alanine d-alanine and
thereby penicillin can interfere with
the process of transportation and
thereby cell wall is not formed properly
and many cross links are not formed so
it's a weak cell wall which is prone to
damage especially osmolarity damage and
all this way so that's why ultimately
the bacteria gets smaller etic damage
and several other damage and thereby the
bacteria dies eventually so thereby
penicillin is one of the important
bacteria Seidel antibiotics which
interferes with a cell wall Association
process and thereby killing the bacteria
in the next video we would look at how
bacterias has grown resistance against
this kind of antibiotics so if you liked
my video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe thank
you for your support
you